what is up there reject nation you know
we were just talking about
what's going on we're gonna watch
brooklyn nine nine today
episode four of season one maybe one day
we'll get around
doing this twice a week hopefully we
even succeeded in getting this up on
sunday
guys hit that like button if you enjoy
our reactions
also subscribe and click that
notification bell
you know what the purpose of that is by
the way full length watch alongs where
you sync it with the time go for banan
over at our patron page and over there
we covered like this show that show
this show and that show and at the same
tier you get the option for
highlights and watch long included
exclusive patreon reactions
and uh yeah i think we're editing this
one one of us is
hope we didn't hopefully public
speaking of this is work sorry captain
called
he needs everybody back there's a lead
on the nightingale strangler yes
white male 510 medium build brown hair
he finds lonely women with no friends
poisons
okay where are you apparently has the
world's smallest penis and doesn't know
how to use it hi there i'm jake peralta
amy's boss
i like the audio shift there yeah your
boss seems really nice he's not my boss
yes i am did you guys hear that i saw
five felonies in one week
we heard really how five felonies in one
week light them up boyle
i just got a doa on bessemer street
you're the primary you're in that's
right girl hey
you're a criminal we have a good
relationship something to share with the
rest of us
santiago peralta was the one that was
talking god you must have been the worst
fourth grader ever
joke's on you i skipped fourth grade
santiago
anything else no oh it's not good for
her
hey boyle i know you haven't had peralta
as a secondary in a while be careful
it can be rough so you were just
borrowing those cars
ask about his bank account ask about his
bank account
ask him about it
[Laughter]
i can be an amazing secondary and i'll
prove it i know you will jake in the box
hey don't ever call me that again
i'm driving we should leave now carry my
bag but
you should pick the music primary
cotton city yourself
yes yes yes it's a great picture sir
i hate it me too
so i have an eyewitness whoa only
problem is the sketch artist is out sick
how do you want me to proceed figure it
out santiago it's your case
yes thank you
are you bowing no
this is how i walk no
seems like he's in a bad mood i don't
know who could tell
tough weekend i went to barbados with my
husband
we wove hats out of palm fronds and swam
with the stingrays
i've never been happier
[Laughter]
without question the funniest story i've
ever heard
any signs of forced entry or a struggle
no you sure about that
looks like maybe his belt had a pretty
epic struggle with his stomach
i'm calling natural causes home
defibrillator and a frequent customer
gift basket from the cardiac wing of
brooklyn methodist
this case is open and shut just like his
mouth was constantly
that was my last fat joke okay diaz
check and see if there's any more meds
yes yep that's exactly what i was gonna
say
no stand up boyle now you're really good
at um doodling
i know you think you're complimenting me
but calling them doodles is an insult
you a big fan of picasso's doodles
sketch artist is out sick and the
captain wants this done right away he's
in a bad mood
is he i can never read them
you have a fun weekend there was a small
fire in my home
i lost many photo albums of treasured
memories
i'm devastated
[Laughter]
he had um dark curly hair and a neck
tattoo
wait wait wait slow down let's start
with the eyes they were brown do you
even want your purse back
[Laughter]
we were going on a cruise together next
week he had pre-purchased the unlimited
soda package
i'm sure the soft drink industry warns
his passing
hey she's uh charlie bae's wife she's in
this always sunny philadelphia
she's an actress from other things
besides it's always sunny in
philadelphia
actually i've been given a direct order
to do nothing so
what brings you here
[Laughter]
you all right what's up
oh bow chicka bow out that looks like
natural causes but i'll know for sure
once i get the autopsy results tomorrow
i'm really glad you could sneak away
from your case
can i ask you guys something can you
keep a secret do you know anything about
my life
no i do not good point i kind of had sex
with her last night
what oh sorry i forgot who i was talking
to sex is something that two adults do
with their bodies when they're attracted
to each other
he's right santiago do you not know that
but i can't tell if what happened was
weird or sexy
wait close your eyes okay
[Music]
oh no no
for some reason i kind of started
getting into it
oh what do we have here
cause of death initial assessment blood
force trauma
but what do i find when i probe a little
farther bruising around the neck
no no how long have you been dead body
oh exploding odors oh uh 24 hours
perfect oh
what are you guys talking about um just
weird sex stuff that has nothing to do
with work
i once had sex on a futon and it was in
couch mode
where'd it go it's resourceful
let's catch those guys who can give hold
some good news i want to cheer him up i
mean it's impossible to read that guy
this is the most incompetent
get your act together or so help me god
you won't live to see retirement
it's like what's that guy thinking you
know
so stupid patterson's wife told me that
they were going to cruise together next
month credit card bill shows only one
ticket booked
she knew he was going to die oh no
autopsy we better go down there see
what's holding him up
good call nice we came by to get that
autopsy report
hmm is detected peralta here i haven't
seen him
thanks for coming by oh no
found him oh thank goodness you're here
i am so lost
do you know where the vending machines
are
[Music]
everyone knows its natural causes not
anymore we think it could be a murder
wait like a murder murder or like his
mouth murdered him by making him meet so
much
god
[Laughter]
we didn't know it was a homicide well it
shouldn't matter i'm your primary and i
asked you to do something
so if it's okay i'd like to be upset
with you it's more than okay
it's okay times two
actually with a body this size i'd named
my assistant and i gave
him the rest of the afternoon off okay
fine
hi no
how gross could it be i'm just gonna
need you to hold open this
chest cavity for me oh wow
she doesn't have her mask on no yeah
he was easy to pick up he looked just
like the sergeant sketch
you could be a professional artist boss
do you think you guys should draw
caricatures
i don't draw giant head people on
surfboards i'm saying you could you're
that good
captain i missed the paperwork by noon
i wanted included in the crime stats i
need you to do one more drawing for me
what ah
scully yeah get me my
oil yes it's like cutting into a big
overstuffed ravioli
yeah i imagined that want to see
something cool
no here it is ah that's what i'm talking
about
listen
mm-hmm that was the air releasing from
the large intestine
here you want to hold it no
[Music]
knock knock you can knock it with your
nose saying it is ridiculous
i threw away the photo because i think
it's ostentatious to hang pictures of
yourself especially when you haven't
earned a place on the wall
but you would have me hang a baroque oil
painting of myself like i'm a north
korean dictator
why am i not ascribe my noble steed clad
in armor no
come on she's trying man you should have
been filing a report on the purse
snatcher
oh i did it's already in the system no
good hmm thank you dismissed
[Laughter]
look at the scarring on this liver cause
of death
poison
[Music]
all right i'm gonna go tell him yeah you
could or
you could stay for a postmortem no
ugh it's nothing personal i just think
sex is for the living
isn't that right buddy oh my god he has
no eyes
you're worried about the monthly crime
statistics the pre-six numbers almost
always get worse under new leadership
but ours didn't that's a win
it's just your first month morale is
much higher people are working
harder you're well on your way to
earning a place on that wall thank you
santiago you know
we're birds of a feather you and i i
[Applause]
think
i love her santiago
uh i don't i don't know if i've seen her
in anything else he drove me to it he
had a fair after affair he was a real
don juan
permission to make a fat joke granted
are you sure you didn't mean don flan
[Laughter]
you were under arrest for the murder
i'm a fraud not at all
i'd like to take this home for my
husband he'll be glad you made me look
so happy
i was trying to make him look serious i
still can't read them no one can
i can he likes it
[Music]
nice job boyle nailed it here of course
he did he's a great primary i may for
the first time have been a bit of a jerk
[Laughter]
rosa you're right wonderful moment
between two guys
oh come on be friends
you sure you're not just sneaking off
for more weird dead guy sex
we will never speak of that again god
crazy day huh i hate small talk it's
drinking silence
perfect
oh i just never
yeah just get her snatch her put her in
a bag
carry her off somewhere and she'll love
you and she'll love you that's how love
works
learn it boyle win her heart quite quite
literally
all right john looks like
i'm inspired oh good it's time for you
to
take the lead on this interview oh cause
you want to be my second
i said interview not review it's in the
video now
yeah so what was second season what was
your inspiration
for uh setting me up to be your primary
on this review
interview greg aren't you glad that you
tossed me that miss speech
to kick off mine is how you're leading
this is how i'm leading with my thoughts
on the episode
guys we don't have time to mess around
okay this was funny he had a good hook
and uh i laughed a lot
greg opening thought
um yeah you know it was
a really funny episode and uh
i thought that uh okay well i'll take it
from here
thank god yeah i thought andy samberg
funny as always but you know who really
shined out this episode was
melissa fumero who plays santiago
yeah yeah yeah she's gorgeous she's very
attractive yeah and she's hilarious at
the same time very funny
or a comedy skill am i stepping on your
turf not at all
comrades or comedy skills
are uh top notch
it's like i noticed it in the pilot but
and like yeah she's got some moments in
the other episodes too i'm always
more impressed with the show when the
when it demonstrates
uh their strong capabilities as
detectives
backed with the insecurities and the
goofiness about the characters
that's when i always i'm more drawn to
the characters and like her here too
especially like having that
that that pool at the end when he was
like scolding her
uh when captain holt was scolding her
and then she was like no it's already
filed
yeah yeah i made i mean i'm like yeah
you're bad at that good you dude
she's really funny she's so funny like
super caring
and i really i really like this uh arc
that they have here with
peralta learning how to be number two to
boil
never had to deal with that before no
you've never had to deal with anything
but someday watch out you know you never
know
it's a lot more challenging than it
looks like being
number two but no i mean that made for a
lot of really fun comedy across the
episode and such a rewarding moment when
boyle actually does
like i thought that was cool because
they made a moment out of that without
like really doing a big lead up so when
he does just kind of cut through the
nonsense when they're in the you know
emmys off in the actual like you know
crea
autopsy room the more yeah when he's
just like you know i told you to do
something you do it you know like
he's great like we were talking last
episode about how much we appreciate his
comedy but also like when he needs to
lay it down i was like oh yeah he can do
it
like you know i believed his authority
for there for a minute
yeah it wasn't like this big dramatic
speech and
really having to instill a learning
lesson yeah you don't need like
a music track to make us feel like boyle
grew
or something you didn't eat a whole big
peralta moment and being like
you're right i'm i'm sorry yeah like i
messed up
and here's everything i learned and now
i'm realizing like you didn't need to
slow it down yeah i get it yeah uh that
was nice
the whoop that that lady from mary
elizabeth ellis who plays dr rossi
i don't know if her and charlie day are
still together do you remember her from
it's always sunny yeah oh yeah
yeah the waitress he's always trying to
get with yeah and the
funny part about that and it's always
sometimes that he's actually with her
yeah yeah i don't know if they still are
together uh but
yeah having her here in this role i
think is uh
that's disgusting that's a disgusting
answer yeah well
then getting to see her in a row where
she gets to have fun with
something like that character who comes
from a different place of confidence
what's it called again when you like to
do dead bodies necrophilia
necrophilia shout it louder for the
youtube reviewers
youtube human reviewers guys this is
what we're talking about
video today is this okay with your ads
well hey i mean it's okay for them to
show autopsy gore on tv because it's
scientific
so you know perhaps
we just approached this bring it up
scientific mind
necrophilia with a scientific mind even
though that's not what happens in this
episode
no it's just a humorous sexy kind of
thing
no but like you can get into anything
you know woman's in the wood enough
you're just like
yeah sure i'll get into it i'll try it
why not why not and we'll see how it
goes who knows maybe i'll unravel my
next
great obsession yeah and also with terry
terry and his heart skills i love that
they cast him for this someone said in
the comments that
they wanted him so bad for the show they
made they named the character terry
and it's just like what they did to make
his character
more sensitive as the show progresses i
love that about him yeah
like he just unravels more and more
sensitivity
um yeah because he's like just this
giant puff dude yeah and he like has a
scary he could be a scary
demeanor or a presence right up front
when looking at him but then
you know like his his wife the dollhouse
and now with all the drawings and being
like
so particular about making sure this is
art
and not just some sketch description
of a suspect that's some funny ass stuff
some funny things to mine oh there's a
show been going on how much comedy can
you mind from
12 seasons apparently what 12th season
is last night we started a long one
we are late we were like seven seasons
that we had to do
unless i'm wrong i could be wrong and no
gina here no
not not once we didn't
not once was gina there but yeah we
don't have to argue about whether or not
we found her funny this
seems to be the most debated thing in
the comments although you know pretty
much everybody also i like that they're
like you know but
i get why you you wouldn't like her
whatever
it's the most like fair explanation of a
character
in the comments i think we've ever
gotten right down the middle on her even
with an episode she's not
in we're still talking about it right
she left an impression there's an
impact out gina important yeah one and
two i mean like
continuing out of the last episode it
does seem
like the further we get in the more
they're doing to
focus on characters who aren't peralta
like you know this seemed more like the
diaz episode in part
yeah you know in terms of her getting to
take the lead that recurring joke about
like nobody being able to read the chief
mate for a lot of really funny bits and
stuff
oh i love the one yeah i like some
sometimes the best com the best comedy
usually is when you expect it to go a
certain way and it doesn't
yeah uh who who is the the dude who's
like i can't read the chief
um and then he's like yelling at him the
chief yeah
is it what's gully scully yeah that's
just a funny mix
the clear
absolutely one two just the way andre
like he
he has this fat like i've seen andre
brower talk and like obviously he's not
quite as clinical and as like
hyper enunciated as he is here and so
the way he's able to deadpan all these
different emotions with just like
little flavors in between are so great
like
he he sells it and then makes it sing
you know
it makes me wonder how much direction
he's really given
yeah for like fun the people who are
directing the episodes or if he just had
this is all like off of his pure
instinct for what's best for the
comments yeah
this comedy relies so much on him like
not
being so deadpan yeah and uh the deadest
pain
yeah that's so good though yeah dude
he's got a magic because there's still a
character in there it's not just the
deadpan
yeah like he's he feels like a fully
alive character
despite how some dude his emotions are
well he really cares
i love that santiago being teacher's pet
was also the one to figure out why he
would be upset
yeah you know yeah it's part of her
detective work anyway guys
another solid episode of brooklyn
nine-nine oh what am i doing
jon please dude what are you doing
we gotta shout some patrons out oh we're
closed i thought we
you know we say subscribe and oh that's
right it's okay
i'll take what am i doing i should stop
guys guys subscribe
click that notification bell to know
when our next brooklyn nine-nine episode
is out or any other reaction video
news story we put up and uh
check us out on patreon we'll see you
next week
and then yeah and then we're probably
gonna and then we'll do a patreon of the
day shout out
to all the people subscribe for our
delete take some bts here just wanna
make y'all feel special college names
how many people do we got a shout out
today
44. david alexander chris
bustin mr crispy
stone pc finales
underscore jesse dobby reactions alex
bieber kathleen marr ashton
fisher pseudonymous entity
olivia delgade kevin casimir
differently sane nash sanodiki
kelly hales jacob gonzalez
levite ideal josh barnes
shawn davis oscar
lauren american horse peter pachaco
joanna saint louis matthew mensing
rogue cree sam
castle sj
and justin manning kayla what is you
rosie beatty darth yoda0666 you son of a
[ __ ] ruby
[Music]
colin anderson philip j smith jr
jenna smith briona davidson
melanie leblanc oh i have accents here
britney bailey oh and natalie dorade
erwin chase gardner
tiana h avedrasdikova
and jack dylan mclovin love all you guys
i love especially melody
out of all 43 i've cited you as my
favorite
song and the next shout out we're going
to rank you all so you better
not land in that bottom 10. everyone is
equal here
except for melanie yeah she's above the
very
top of the list you're all you all got a
ways to go
ketchup but seriously just joking you're
all
great fantastic humans and thank you so
much for showing your support our way to
each and every one of you
literally it's been a busy month this
week in particular is quite
chaotic for us so you guys showing your
hard-earned dollars our way
hopefully you guys have been enjoying
the content over there but believe me
when i say it your support
is not overlooked especially you
melanie especially